Omar Abdullah is a mother of four living
in the occupied West Bank she's buying
food for her family from ramallah's main
food market fruits and vegetables are
slightly cheaper here blind many
Palestinian households the monthly
budget doesn't go that far
the situation in the country now is that
there is a bigger divide in social
economic classes those working in Israel
are just managing the rest of the
Palestinians working in the occupied
West Bank especially government
employees they are the ones really
struggling may God be with them
26 year old and unemployed
meets a friend trying to help him get a
job in West Jerusalem salaries there are
higher but Israel restricts Palestinians
from entering the city meaning there are
no guarantees and costs of transport to
get there is expensive
four to five years being a land broker
was more dignified than now prices are
more expensive and there's no money for
the home or family there's nothing no
jobs
thank you
the economy is struggling and according
to the Palestinian Central Bureau of
Statistics it only grew by 3.6 last year
that's half of 2021's growth now just to
give you an idea on the high cup prices
a tray of eggs last month cost three
dollars now they cost almost six and
being able to serve meat on the dining
table is considered a luxury these days
the Palestinian Authority says it's
taking measures to reduce the cost of
basic Commodities analysts say if this
continues with costs Rising Palestinian
families are going to struggle to make
ends meet we might even see more
protests
Palestinian Authority has told Al
Jazeera plans to spend 50 million
dollars to prop up the fuel and flower
sectors and fix prices for some basic
Goods they are constrained by the money
that Israel sends to them they're
constrained by
less funding from the donor Community
but at the same time they're expected to
manage the economy by increased spending
so they have their constraints
the pandemic war in Ukraine and years of
economic challenges under Israeli
occupation have hurt Palestinians
Israel's withholding of vital tax funds
from the Palestinian Authority means
government salaries aren't received on
time the funds account for more than 60
percent of its annual revenue
dawood wants to show us how successful
his online business was before being
unemployed
I tell him it looks like he has plenty
of online followers he agrees while
showing us his Facebook page where he
sold homemade meals and Arabic coffee
Delwood may have lost his business
because he could no longer afford the
ingredients he needed but he says he
hasn't lost hope of finding a new job
in the occupied West Bank